[Music]
ah
yeah harry potter fam i'm back with
another special lesson for you
today we'll see harry and his classmates
in herbology class
in their second year at hogwarts
herbology is a real science that studies
herbs and medicinal plants
in the wizarding world it studies
magical plants as we'll see in today's
scene
this will be a great opportunity for you
to learn some specific vocabulary in
english about
plants and gardening as you probably
already know
this is one of the great things about
learning english with different movies
and series
they give you all sorts of real life
situations that can be useful in gaining
english fluency
are you ready for some fun let's dive in
[Music]
morning everyone
good morning everyone welcome to
greenhouse three second years now gather
round everyone
today we're going to re-pop mandrakes
who here can tell me the properties of
the mandrake route
yes miss granger mandrake
or mandagora is used to return those
who've been petrified
to their original state it's also quite
dangerous
the mandrake's cry is fatal to anyone
who hears it
excellent 10 points to gryffindor now as
our mandrakes are still only seedlings
their cries won't kill you yet
but they could knock you out for several
hours which is why i've given each of
you a pair of earmuffs for auditory
protection
so could you please put them on right
away quickly
[Music]
morning everyone
good morning everyone so
here we meet the herbology professor at
hogwarts
professor pomona sprout sprout is her
surname
but it is also a word in english in the
context of plants
to sprout is to begin to develop leaves
and other parts
as we can see here happening with this
plan by the way
did you know that professor and teacher
do not mean the same thing
in the real world professor is a title
normally given to a teacher at a
university or
college because they have more studies
than a normal teacher
teacher is a more general word which
refers to the professional who educates
others
however in the world of harry potter the
teachers at hogwarts are called
professors
even though they teach young children
morning everyone
good morning everyone by the way
the children tell her good morning but
did you notice that her greeting before
was simply
morning morning everyone it's extremely
common for natives to drop the word good
in these common greetings
so instead of good morning good
afternoon
good evening good night we will simply
say
morning afternoon evening night
example evening do you know what you
would like to drink
check out these other examples afternoon
men
sheldon
evening officer even license and
registration please
good morning hey that was my favorite
genius and his little robot buddy
don't touch it okay good morning
good morning morning
good morning paul hey do you want to
learn more about how natives
really speak in everyday situations
while having fun
with your favorite tv series well then
our flume with friends course is perfect
for you
you will learn to understand how natives
really speak with lessons that follow
along with the 48 episodes of the first
two seasons
of friends which various studies have
shown is the best series out there
for learning english you can try it for
free right now
with our three-part mini course all you
have to do is click up at the top or
down in the description below
to learn more and sign up and if you do
i hope you'll really enjoy it
good morning everyone welcome to green
house three second years
as we can hear professor sprout say this
herbology class is taking
place at greenhouse number three a
greenhouse is a building that usually
looks like a house but that has
roofs and sides made of glass used for
growing plants that need warmth and
protection
and as you probably know she refers to
the students as second years
as they are in their second year of
studies at hogwarts
welcome to greenhouse three second years
now gather round everyone
together is to bring together things or
people at one location
example we gathered a lot of apples from
the trees
all the people gathered to watch the
show
it was dark times very dark times
voldemort started to gather some
followers
brought him over to the dark side
so professor sprout is asking the
students to gather around her so she can
start the class
also to gather around is a common
phrasal verb
and it can normally be heard as a
command by itself
example gather around the show is about
to start
follow me everyone keep up quickly come
on
[Music]
gather around here
welcome to the gryffindor common room
today we're going to re-pot mandrakes
who here can tell me the properties of
the mandrake root
the root of a plant is the part that
grows down into the earth to get water
and nutrients
and holds the plant firmly into the
ground
the professor is asking about the
properties that is the characteristics
or attributes of a mandrake
and this is what a real mandrake root
looks like now
in the wizarding world the mandrake root
is magical
and it looks alive and moves just like a
human baby
in this class the students are going to
re-pot
mandrakes to pot is a specific verb used
in gardening
which means to put a plant or seed into
a pot with soil
so to repot it just means to move a
plant that has already been potted
into a new pot this is normally done in
order to give plants more space to grow
as they change in sizes today we're
going to re-pot
mandrakes who here can tell me the
properties of the mandrake route
yes ms granger mandrake
or mandagora is used to return those
who've been petrified
to their original state in fantasy
stories if somebody
or something is petrified they or it is
turned into stone
for example these creatures were
petrified and became like statues
[Music]
in the real world this word also means
to be extremely frightened
or so terrified that you are unable to
move
example she felt petrified when her mom
found cigarettes in her room
so every single week we make lessons
with movies like harry potter
series like friends and interviews with
celebrities like taylor swift
so that you can understand fast speaking
natives without getting lost
without missing the jokes and without
subtitles for example this subscriber
says
that he's improving his english by
watching one of our lessons
every single day and we can help you on
your path to fluency too
all you have to do is hit that subscribe
button and the bell down below
so you don't miss a single one of our
new lessons
it's also quite dangerous the mandrake's
cry is fatal to anyone who hears it
if something is fatal it causes death
for example a stunning spell is not
fatal
as it just leaves the target unconscious
that is not awake
on the other hand a vaticandavra is a
fatal spell
as it is used for killing the target
professor sprout is saying that the man
drake's cry
kills anyone who hears it now as our
mandrakes are still only
seedlings their cries won't kill you yet
a seedling is a very young plant
still in its initial phase of growth but
they could knock you out for several
hours which is why i've given each of
you a pair of earmuffs
for auditory protection so could you
please put them on right away
quickly to knock someone out means to
cause or
force them to become unconscious or to
go to sleep
for example the stunning spell stupefy
can be used to knock
in a boxing match you lose if you get
knocked out
this is also abbreviated to a ko
is it dead i don't think so
lust not doubt in the scene she's saying
that these
mandrakes are still very young so
hearing their cry will not kill you
but it will leave you unconscious
but they could knock you out for several
hours which is why i've given each of
you a pair of earmuffs
for auditory protection as you can
already see the students wearing them
earmuffs are a pair of ear coverings
such as these
which protect your ears against loud
noises or cold temperatures
auditory is an adjective more used in
medical context
that defines anything involving hearing
like an auditory disease or auditory
equipment
so could you please put them on right
away when talking about clothing or
items that you can wear to put something
on simply means to start wearing
something
for example hogwarts students need to
put their black robes on to go to class
what is it some kind of cloak
well let's see then put it on
whoa so could you please put them on
right away
right away or straight away means
immediately
right now
[Music]
not to worry harry i will fix that arm
of yours straight away
now remember any sign of movement close
your eyes straight away
[Music]
flaps tight down and watch me closely
you
grasp your mandrake firmly you'll
pull it sharply over the port
[Music]
got it and now you dunk it down into the
other pot
and pour a little sprinkling of soil to
keep him warm
long bottom's been neglecting his
earmuffs
no ma'am he's just fainted yeah as well
just leave him there right on we go
plenty of pots to go around
grasp your mandrake and pull it up
[Music]
flaps tight down and watch me closely by
flaps
she's referring to these parts of the
ear muffs something that is tight is
firmly or closely fixed in place
not easily moved for example this is a
loose knot and this is a tight knot
tight is an adjective the verb is to
tighten
so if you tighten something down you are
making it more
flaps tight down and watch me closely to
watch closely is to pay attention to a
situation that
interests or worries you as to see how
it develops
example the presentation will only be
explained once
so watch it closely you grasp
your mandrake firmly literally to grab
something is to take it into your hand
and hold it as she does with the
mandrake
another useful and practical definition
of this word means to understand
something
example do you grasp what i'm saying i
didn't really grasp all the parts of the
professor's lecture
can you help me to understand it
it's impossible to grasp just how
powerful love
is you grasp
your mandrake firmly you pull it sharply
to pull something out is to take
something out of the interior of
something
like to pull your notebook out of your
backpack or to pull your wallet out of
your pocket
gryffindor to pull that out of the hat
[Music]
in this case she's pulling the mandrake
out of the pot
have you seen all of our harry potter
lessons yet well you can find all of our
lessons with the movies and
interviews by clicking up at the top or
down the description below after you
finish this video
you pull it
[Music]
to perform a movement sharply is to do
it in a quick intense or
sudden way
[Music]
one of the possible meanings of the verb
to get is to understand
much like the verb grasp that we saw
before
example if they aren't getting it
explain it in a different way
and you
are you coming are you staying
fine i get it
i saw you two the other night brothers
that's nothing
got it so you can informally ask got it
meaning the same as
do you understand you dunk it down into
the other pot
and pour a little sprinkling of soil to
keep him warm
to dunk something into a place such as a
cup jar
or pot is simply to put something inside
of that recipient in a vigorous
way for example you might dunk cookies
in milk or coffee
to pour something is normally used to
refer to making a substance flow out of
container
and into another container for example i
spilled some milk while pouring it into
the bowl
in the case of the scene she means that
she's taking the soil from one pot and
adding it to another
a sprinkling is a small amount of drops
or particles of a substance
for example sprinklings of water or sand
this comes from the verb to sprinkle
which means to drop small amounts of
something onto or
into something else so we could also say
the professor sprout
is sprinkling soil into the pot now
you dunk it down into the other pot and
pour a little
sprinkling of soil to keep him warm
long bottom's been neglecting his
earmuffs if you are responsible for
something and you neglect it
that means you do not give it the
necessary attention or care
in this case the professor thinks
neville did not take care to wear his
earmuffs properly
and because of that he became
unconscious
longbottom's been neglecting his
earmuffs
no ma'am he's just fainted to faint is
to suddenly become unconscious for a
short time
usually falling down example she faints
every time she sees blood
plenty of pots to go around grasp your
man drake
and pull it up if there is plenty of
something there there's an amount that
is enough
or more than enough for what will be
needed for example if you go to a party
and there's plenty of food
that means there's lots of food and that
it should be enough to feed
everyone there
[Music]
morning everyone
good morning everyone welcome to
greenhouse
three second years now gather round
[Music]
everyone
today we're going to re-pop mandrakes
who here
can tell me the properties of the
mandrake root
yes miss granger mandrake
or mandagora is used to return those
who've been petrified
to their original state it's also quite
dangerous
the mandrake's cry is fatal to anyone
who hears it
excellent 10 points to gryffindor now as
our mandrakes are still only seedlings
their cries won't kill you yet
but they could knock you out for several
hours which is why i've given each of
you a pair of earmuffs
for auditory protection so could you
please put them on right away
quickly flaps tight down
and watch me closely you grasp
your mandrake firmly
[Music]
you'll pull it shut over
got it and now you dunk it down into the
other pot
and pour a little sprinkling of soil to
keep it warm
[Music]
long bottom's been neglecting his
earmuffs
no ma'am he's just fainted yeah as well
just leave him there right on we go
plenty of pots to go around
grasp your mandrake and pull it up
[Music]
awesome job today i hope you understood
a lot better that second time around
and got a hundred percent on the quiz
remember we're here to help you on your
path to fluency
so be sure to check out this other video
that i know you're going to love
and subscribe so you don't miss any of
our new lessons with harry potter
and other movies and series that you're
going to really enjoy
now it's time to go beyond the classroom
and live your english oh yeah